[Applaudissements]
okami on a bâti de l'année juste avant
il était venu là dans la faune n'avait
pas joué au ping pong norman voulais me
défier au ping pong ou pas parce que
j'ai eu très chaud là je suis libre
connaît pas chaud à moins que le public
me motive oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le manque d'information
[Applaudissements]
avant le tuto de matthieu delormeau
normal si vous gagnez en deux points
si vous gagnez vous êtes obligé de faire
une vidéo expressément sur touche pas à
mon poste c'est bien une vidéo que pour
nous c'est que les vidéos de norman
c'est la folie quoi sert un cadeau de fo
pour nous en revanche si vous gagnez je
ferai une spéciale norman même sans vous
d'accord on voyait missions spéciales
normales
je vais voir ok on valide ses prêts en
dessous une petite bombe
ok bon allez attention c'est pas là on
considère qu on va la faire aux trois
points on commence à marcher maintenant
aller avoue ne sait rien alors fait le
bac bon allez je fais exprès vous avez
déjà des idées sur la vidéo c'est en
train de se créer allez mais non
attention dernier tous les ans il sait
la balle de match nul à chier je suis
vraiment ramé la révolte se jouer sur
une étape plus grande d'habitude
[Applaudissements]
la pollution
à hi hi hi hi hi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non non
pour nous le nordmann non match